[Música]
en aquí en colombia se pierden
aproximadamente 20 20 hectáreas de
bosques cada hora debido a la
deforestación eso es algo más o menos
como 28 campos de fútbol pensarías que
esto es una cifra impresionante verdad
tengo claro que esta gran deforestación
se debe a las fronteras agrícolas y
ganaderas que se dan en nuestra región
va a ser principal y fundamental de la
economía en mi municipio planeta rica y
en mi caso la agricultura como campesino
fui criado bajo la falsa creencia de que
deforestar y quemar era bueno y
proporcionaba nutrientes a nuestros
suelos eso nos enseñaban nuestros
ancestros nuestros abuelos que para
poder cultivar debíamos quemar y que
esas cenizas eran buenas para nuestros
suelos
hoy en día me doy cuenta de que eso es
totalmente falso porque para poder
obtener una buena cosecha debemos
reforestar y utilizar esa capa vegetal
como abono que es a su vez le
proporciona micronutrientes a nuestros
suelos y así obtener una buena cosecha
en mi comunidad palmas de oro
hemos venido aprendiendo a trabajar y
hacer resilientes trabajando de la mejor
forma para no hacerle daño a nuestro
medio ambiente
sembrando barreras vivas alrededor de
nuestras cosechas para que cuando vengan
los fuertes vientos un fenómeno que se
da en nuestra región eso pueda mitigar
un poco que cuando vengan la fuerte
brisa se lleven todo a su paso por eso
nosotros sembramos barreras vivas y como
también en nuestra región en nuestra
zona se dan
el fuerte verano nosotros sembramos
arbustos en todas nuestras cañadas para
así poder subsistir y tener agua cuando
venga la sequía
tengo claro que si ponemos en práctica
las buenas prácticas agrícolas podemos
obtener unos buenos resultados en mi
comunidad palmas de oro
trabajamos
con el llame
año a año y hemos también heredado de
nuestros abuelos algo que se llama la a
media si tú tienes tierra yo cultivo y
te doy cosecha si tú no tienes tierra yo
te doy la tierra tú la cosechas y luego
partimos la cosecha tengo entendido que
esto era utilizado por nuestras tribus
indígenas para hacer trabajos
comunitarios nosotros lo hemos puesto en
práctica en nuestra comunidad y año tras
año hemos venido cultivando ya menos
solamente para el consumo de nuestras
familias sino también para obtener un
beneficio económico
si en nuestra comunidad lo hemos logrado
también pienso que todo el mundo puede
hacerlo
porque la agricultura va de la mano con
el medio ambiente debemos de juntar
esfuerzos para trabajar sin hacerle daño
al medio ambiente o al entorno en el
cual vivimos para así tener una mejor
calidad de vida y tampoco afectando a
los ecosistemas muchas gracias